las vegas now as the weather continues
to warm up the best way to enjoy lunch
is outside and you can do so at the
front yard at ellis island and here to
tell us about their newly launched lunch
menu is general manager christina ellis
christina thanks for being here thanks
for having me i'm really excited when
you guys started setting up i said the
flowers are beautiful the pizza looks
great we have a whole vibe going here
tell us about the lunch menu and what
people can expect absolutely so lunch
spring perfect time to enjoy great food
and drinks outside which is what we have
at the front yard of course so here
today we have our blt with avocado so
black if it's written down
and all of our bacon we cure in-house so
that's something you can only find at
the front yard
i can smell it now it smells so good
then moving on we have our honey pig
which is just like a classic front yard
food it's a pepperoni pizza and we put
hot honey over the top i was wondering
what was drizzled on top there that
looks amazing yeah so you get a little
bit sweet from the honey but also the
spice from the pepperoni and the honey
so a little sweet and salty it's the
perfect combination exactly what else we
have over there and we have our akituna
salad which is sliced aki tuna with some
spring mix some edamame and quinoa in
there very light refreshing especially
during those hot spring days absolutely
those are coming up quickly so this is
the perfect menu to kick it off and you
know you can't have food without a
little drink what's on the menu as far
as drinks go absolutely so in the front
yard we have 12 beers that we brew
in-house at ellis island
yeah including one of our beers that was
named gold at the great american beer
festival this year oh hey that's a huge
honor yeah we're gonna have to try that
in a second here but we were talking
before i've been to ellis island i've
been to the front yard for brunch you're
still doing brunch on the weekends yes
so what are the hours and when can
people come in to try all this yummy
lunch stuff yes so we have brunch
saturday sunday monday and then lunch is
tuesday through friday from 11 to 3.
perfect so any time of day you can go in
and get something great to eat you guys
also do so many fun events i know you've
had live podcasts you've done
oktoberfest st patrick's day you guys
are just always keeping it fun and
exciting right tons of fun stuff
especially coming up for easter and
mother's day and even earth day we have
some stuff coming so hey always a reason
and excuse to celebrate we'll take it
well thank you so much for bringing all
this before we wrap up i feel like we
have to do a little cheers with the beer
i think we have to let's go in for it
okay i love anything cute and little
like this so cheers christina thank you
so much go try the new lunch menu at the
front yard at ellis island can't go
wrong with any of this right absolutely
all right i'll send it over to you jc
looks delicious the last